reclusive fitness guru Richard Simmons
appeared to be reaching out to fans more
than three years after he disappeared
from public view he was hospitalized
Monday for what his spokesperson called
severe indigestion Simmons apparently
took to Facebook yesterday to thank
everyone for their well wishes he also
reassured his concern fans that he's
okay Kevin Frazier from our partners at
Entertainment Tonight is in Los Angeles
Kevin good morning good morning you know
you could argue that up until 2014 there
was no a public figure who was more
public than Richard Simmons and that's
why his continued absence and his latest
statement are so fascinating the main
thing fitness superstar Richard Simmons
seems to be exercising these days is his
right to privacy he hasn't been seen in
public for more than three years but
Simmons apparently decided it was time
to reassure fans he's okay after being
hospitalized in Los Angeles for a
gastric problem Monday this post
appeared Wednesday on his Facebook page
hello to everyone who has shown concern
for me and sent their good wishes I'm
sure I will be feeling good and back
home in a couple of days after
overcoming his own obesity Simmons
dedicated his life to helping others get
healthy he described his journey this
way to Sunday morning in 2010 he got
himself together and then he decided to
be the Pied Piper of health but three
years ago the Pied Piper apparently
decided to leave his followers behind he
gave up his multi-million dollar fitness
empire videos books and lucrative public
appearances one fan and friend Dan to
burski felt so confused and abandoned
that earlier this year he produced a
podcast heard by millions missing
Richard Simmons Richard Simmons
completely and inexplicably stopped
being Richard Simmons and I want to find
out why but in Wednesday's post Simmons
offers this response well by now you
know I'm not missing just a little under
the weather now even though the picture
in Richards post is very similar to a
photo taken in 2013 his spokesperson
assures Entertainment Tonight that
Richard did
the post and i just want to point out
that it ends with this line hope to see
you again soon I think everyone is
hoping to see Richard soon Gail you're
absolutely right about that Kevin so
still no one has seen him and we don't
really know if that's a recent picture
correct that's right all right but
you're right everybody is pulling Graham
we want them to be okay they are thanks
a lot good to see this morning